pleased to have back here on the program
one of our favorites that we
enjoy watching talk about uh the the
association that he played
for so many years in and one in as well
now he's one of the best announcers
talking about it on espn
as well as locally along with iron eagle
uh broadcasting nets games
richard jefferson back here in the rich
eisen show how are you doing richard
i'm great rich thanks for having me you
got it so
um what do you think the state of the
nets are right now as you and i are
sitting here talking
richard well i i think looking back on
that game three
that grinded out and how important it
was a lot of people saw
that as like oh well the nets aren't
going to shoot like
this and kyrie and kevin are going to be
fine but
and i i've always felt this the longer
this series goes the more it favors
milwaukee
uh from the standpoint of you know
you lose james harden in that you know
and after the second play
now you're asking kevin and kai and and
kyrie
to to hold down the fort against high
level basketball oh excuse me
and they haven't done that consistently
so um
you know they've had injuries they've
been banged up and covered protocol but
now you're like
oh you got to go six games against
boston you got to go
five six seven games against milwaukee
you got to go five six seven games
against
philly or whoever's coming out on that
side so i just think that
you know the nets because of their
injuries
and i think losing that game three and
that tight one
i think the momentum is completely
shifted especially now with the kyrie
injury that that's
you know even if he misses a week that
that pretty much in my opinion probably
puts them in a very very difficult
position so
it does look like in your opinion that
this is going to have to be
finished up by durant and the rest of
the supporting cast
minus the two other super teamers
on the roster that's the way you're
looking at it right now yeah
and even when you look at you know let's
go back in the past and look at some
injuries
you know i i'll stand by it toronto did
everything that they needed to do
and kawhi leonard had one of the best
runs that we had seen in a while
but ultimately kevin durant being out
and clay thompson being out is the
reason why
the golden state warriors didn't win a
championship and right now you have a
situation where
james harden is hamstring that he's been
dealing with for months now
and there is no timetable and even you
can only count on
what you can count on so even if you
know he's able to come back in
in a week or able to come back in a
couple of days that hamstring has been
giving him problems for months it set
him out so
how can you really you know take into
account
you know can he really do the type of
load
especially with kyrie being out so it's
just been
it's very tough i i believe in kevin
durant one of the best players in the
world
i'm not saying that that guy can't win
two games by himself
but the road is definitely very very
difficult
richard jefferson uh here on the rich
eisen show
what do what do you know about hardin
anything what are you hearing about his
hamstring and really that there's not
much to be said you know rich you've
been doing this
you know since you know before i was
born
i know you know those hamstrings
especially it's like the minute you hear
hamstring the first thing you hear
is reoccurring like in your brain you
hear reoccurring right
from standpoint of like it happens once
you try and come back too early
then it happens again and then now it's
just something that
a maintenance to get you through the
season and you know hamstrings are just
one of those like injuries that if you
don't take two
three months off it's never going to
fully heal and there's always going to
be twins there's always going to be
you know things so i haven't heard
anything specifically i haven't even
heard much about kyrie's ankle
but again giving it the eye test kyrie
had his hands full with drew holiday
being a hundred percent healthy
like drew holly was doing a very good
job though both those guys were
competing really well
so now you know with kyrie with that
ankle let's say kyrie's at 70
like even if he's able to go out there
and he's at 70 75
that doesn't give you know a lot of room
for error still
so i just think it's very very difficult
the position that they're in
now again we've seen crazier things you
got kevin durant on your team you got a
chance
right like it doesn't matter who you're
playing against who the other five guys
you have a chance
might be small but you have a chance
richard jefferson here on the rich eisen
show so what do you think is going
through durant's mind
very you know um very
few athletes are seemingly as attuned to
what is being said about him
quite like kevin and you know the silly
backlash that occurred during the second
half of that game yesterday is that
look at what durant looks like without
his super team friends
um so what do you think his mindset is
right now as you and i are talking going
into that crucial game five
tuesday night richard well i you know i
don't i don't want to speak for kevin
durant because i don't i don't know his
mindset
i know that he's one of those guys just
like every great player goes out there
with something to prove
um that's always that's just how they're
made up kobe's the
lebrons uh they just go out there with
something to prove not that they need
validation but that's how they stay
motivated after all the accolades and
all the success like
every time they step on the court
they're trying to prove something
uh i don't make a ton of all that bs
that's being said because people just
want to crack jokes but
kevin durant is different than some of
the other great players
like james harden is one of those guys
that can give you 35 and 10
so he's getting other people involved uh
luca doncic another guy that give you
you know 35 40 and 10 lebron james you
know those are guys that just
they are in an offense amongst
themselves you plot them on the floor
they're going to go get their points and
they're going to make sure that they're
responsible for 20 30 points the other
side
i think kevin durant is more of just a
lethal lethal score
and so for him he's got to figure out a
way to get other people involved because
he has that ability
but also he's got to go out there and
make sure he's putting up 35
35-ish points you know if they're going
to have a chance to win this series so
um i don't know his mindset but i think
he's definitely doing the equation of
what is it that i need to do
to be successful in this series let's
put in perspective if you can for us
um richard jefferson what chris paul's
doing
uh you're somebody who who retired from
the nba at the age of 37 here he is at
the age of 36 doing what he did
not just last night but in that entire
series doing what he did coming back
from
what looked like a very serious shoulder
uh injury against the lakers
put in perspective from your perspective
what um
chris paul's been doing if you know you
know it's
i think we make too much of these legacy
talks and all of this other stuff
uh but i know chris paul is just he's
just been doing it for so long his
defense his offense is
his focus you know he's definitely as
much as he's you know
running the young players right now he's
always had an old school
grinded type of aggressive vibe to him
that's just chris paul
and you know people joke and say he rubs
people the wrong way but
you know i've been having conversations
just like where would you rank chris
paul
all the time and i was like dude chris
paul goes in nba finals like at this
point in time
there's probably only four or five point
guards
that you would even consider that could
be better than him in modern day i'm not
going to go back to the bob koozies and
that space but
you know if you're talking about jason
kidd magic johnson
john stockton steve nash isaac how many
like the list is very very small
if you look at defensively offensively
what is able to do
and then the longevity and what he's
able to do
um you know there's conversations about
him you know people
you know basically giving up on them you
know ship them off to okc
they're not sure what they're going to
do he takes them to the postseason
has a little value then james jones
decides to
you know say hey come on come do what
you did in
in okc come do it in phoenix and he has
delivered
in spades it's been so so impressive so
i'm still curious to see how it ends up
you know i don't know who's going to
come out on that other side but
utah clippers builder those are that's a
big big matchup but phoenix looks
really good right now well let me tell
you man just seeing chris paul
being in the nba finals and then i i
would love to see the nets there as well
to be honest with you just for the fact
that
you know chris paul uh blake griffin
deandre
jordan all in an nba finals although on
separate teams and then the
other person who's right there is
hardened apparently with whom he did not
famously get along to that's why he
wound up at okc winding up
in phoenix i mean that would be off the
charts
i mean that would be awesome definitely
there would definitely be some
some uh some uh poeticness to that
but uh we'll see i think phoenix looks
like they're in a good
spot they obviously whoever they're
gonna get next is going to be a load but
i think the brooklyn nets right now
have a lot on their plate um and and i'm
very very curious to see how how they
react to it
so what do you what did you think of
jokic getting ejected
do you think he deserved it no no
it's just so tough and we know as
players like we're all looking for
competitive edges
somebody swipes at you and you're going
to go down and hold your nose
and you're going to go down but it's
just like even when you look at the
replay
he didn't hit his face am i was i
missing something
i thought he it was the big huge windup
his size
the size of uh who he hit the fact that
uh he did seem to make contact with his
face i mean we got a still photograph
right now he just looks like one of
those wing fighters coming in
to take out an ewok you know what i mean
like it just
it doesn't look fair um so we we also
have to but
we also have to take into account that
players will embellish it
players will embellish it because look
if the mpp is thrown
out of the game or something happens it
benefits you
you don't care i'll look i'll flop to
get the mvp thrown out of the game right
now
give me a jersey i'll go out there i'll
go out there for
it and do anything i can to get him out
of the game but i
look i i think the nba is doing their
best to clean up stuff but
you know sometimes you come up with
solutions to
problems that didn't exist and i think
the mba has done that
in a lot of different instances you're
trying to come up with
you know solutions that problems that
weren't even necessary
you know all the reviews all the
different things that are going on
now it's just a little flagrant once you
have people that have watched the game
of basketball
their entire lives like mark jackson and
doris burke and jeff van gundy
and they they are 50 50 on the flagrant
calls
like those guys have sat there in those
seats for for 15 years
and they literally are 50 50 on or is
that a flagrant
well i don't think we called a flavor
last week on that is that a flag or what
so it just shows you that they need to
address it they need to make things a
little bit more clear and they need to
make sure that
you know while you're trying to protect
the players you also have to look at it
and see that players are trying to
embellish
to get the competitive advantage if you
had to choose a one seed remaining for
most likely to win at all which one
would it be uh utah
yeah yeah they just look so good
and i know the clippers the clippers are
starting to play well i think people are
starting to realize that t
liu teams they get better as series goes
on
right like he just starts to figure it
out he's very big on you know
karma a chess player and i think now
you know where you causing a little bit
of trouble i think taking zubach off
and playing uh batum now you're forcing
rudy the whole time to guard to guard
a small player uh not having serge ibaka
is the one that really hurts him because
sarah debaca could stretch the floor
and he could guard rudy and give you uh
some presents like from the shop
blocking standpoint
obviously he's hurt but like you just
look back and it's like oh
serge ibaka would have been huge in this
series right because he would have done
everything to to offset some of the
stuff that rudy gilbert does but
i just think that their team is so
locked in as a team they're well
balanced they got jordan clarkson off
the bench and they let him do what he
does and he delivers
uh you got conley you got so many
shooters
and it's not just donovan mitchell it's
not just a good defensive team
you just have depth and balance and i
think right now
utah looks so good where philly has that
you know that they're still dealing with
some stuff obviously you don't know
about md's health and
all the stuff surrounding that but i
think utah has been the most impressive
team with phoenix being a close second
plus donovan mitchell's the greatest
player in the history of the jazz right
richard oh man
wow man stephen a that's your guy that's
your guy
i do love him i do love him you've got
to love him but i'm like stephen hey
like come on like even and i didn't go
as far as to say
that uh but even if he wins a
championship this year
he ain't the greatest player in the jazz
so like let's not start doing that is he
on his way
but i just think that people need to
understand that like
the competitiveness that goes you know
luka doncic has had historic years he's
not the best player to ever play for the
mavericks
right like that's just not the truth
it's not the truth now is he on his way
you know another seven eight years of it
yeah we're going to be talking about
like him being better than dirk but
let's not give people that are five six
seven years
into their career you know and then now
all of a sudden we want to put them in
a place with people that did it for 20.
like i just think that's unfair
i know it's fun clickbait but i think
that's unfair to how
hard people worked for dan their two
decades to establish
who they are and what they stood for to
to just kind of
gloss over that quickly okay so to wrap
this thing up richard other than just
get healthy
what do the nets need to do what what
can be done
that can be somewhat controlled um
to get them where they need to go which
is the next round
what do you have for me on that front i
i really think that they just have to
shoot the ball really well and i think
kevin durant when you look at they don't
truly have a backup point guard
um you know mike james is more of a
scorer
um so i i think they kevin durant's got
to get you eight nine assists and got to
get you 30 35 points
guys are gonna have to shoot the ball
well and they're gonna have to keep
playing defense i know there's a lot of
questions about the net defense
but their defense has actually been i
don't want
a non-story but it's been a non-story
because they haven't been lacking
in defense so uh i think they're just
gonna have to shoot the ball
you know pretty crazily over the next
two games uh because milwaukee looks
like their shooting is starting to pick
up these guys are starting to settle in
so that's really it i think their
defense has been quality enough
they just got to make sure that they're
hitting enough shots and that's going to
be difficult without
two of the great scorers you know in the
league on the team
richard jefferson i appreciate it i
always enjoy our chats
you always make me smarter and if you
don't mind i'll look for my call over
the next couple of uh rounds as well
i'd love to 100 man i appreciate you
having me on always thank you that's uh
richard jefferson i follow him on
twitter
uh you should as well what is at rjeff24
correct
on twitter hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here